[Música]
não tá morto nada como é que você se
sente
morto
por quê
Por causa desses testes
da vida você vai pensando
E por que que você acha isso
da onde você acha que vem isso eu acho
que não tenha certeza a minha vida mesmo
esse negócio de aprender lições
aprendizagem Isso é para você ficar mais
forte mais forte vou virar o que um
Vingador e você acha que isso vem dos
seus seguidores é tá vendo Ah vai levar
para o seguidores já vai levar para o
negócio da fama É isso aí que me deixa
desconexo da realidade eu fico fora da
realidade porque parece que eu sou um
monte de gente só que eu não sou um
monte de gente tá legal que um monte de
gente me vê mas eu sou só eu só eu não
sou várias pessoas
Então é a fama é a fama que te futuca
ai doutor eu queria
todo dia futuca um pouquinho mas a forma
possível só é bom é legal bacana você
você ser conhecido você também tem muito
amor né você ganha capinha de celular às
vezes nem é do modelo do seu celular que
você ganha às vezes eu acho que a pessoa
que dela ela tá sabendo que não é o
modelo do seu celular para você não usar
você ganha carregador de celular
eles acende né na ponta os falce você
tinha Sabe eles eles acendem a hora que
a gente bota eles acende eu acho tão
legal aqui mas é uma semana só mas aí a
gente ganha Você conhece as pessoas
também né eu conheci
o mano brown sim mano brown chama Pedro
Paulo nem sabia
são informações que a fama me trouxe
Às vezes você ganha também coisa que é
complicada ganha Eu já ganhei um
Rondônia eu ganhei uma melancia com meu
rosto e eu não era nem famoso ainda
quero que deixava as coisas estranhas
para falar a verdade o povo olhava pra
mim falava meu Deus quem é este rapaz
com tanto amor próprio que sai por aí
com seu rosto gravado e uma melancia
Rondônia tive que trazer de Rondônia
melancia com meu rosto e as pessoas
julgam viu as pessoas elas julgam alguém
que anda por aí com uma melancia com seu
rosto na própria melancia ela julgam sim
pizza é uma coisa que é [ __ ] vim
conhecer pizza eu tinha 16 anos Doutor
isso é uma coisa Longe longe longe longe
longe de todo mundo eu é só no arroba eu
dou uma arroba pizza o que te incomoda
esse tanto de gente né porque na
realidade
a sua opinião não é só a sua opinião
ela sempre tem que ser pensando num bem
maior
concorda sempre para um bem maior de
todo coletivo e eu
fiz uma coisa se você não fosse
famoso
se não fosse você ia trabalhar como o
quê e famoso é trabalhar aonde Doutor
isso aí é que confunde também as pessoas
não Imaginário Popular botar que o
famoso é um trabalho famoso é trabalhar
não é trabalho a pessoa Ser famosa é só
que tem mais gente que olha para ela
trabalha é o cara que cata lixo é o cara
que é pedreiro é o cara que é ator isso
aí é trabalho falando em famoso você vê
que as agências agora não chama os
atores que não tem seguidores tem que
ter seguidor não importa a qualidade Não
importa se é bom ator Justamente não
interessa para eles eles querem aqueles
que tem seguidores isso é verdade mas
nunca nessa aí não viu Doutor
se você não fosse ator seria trabalhar
com o quê
biólogo
sério nada a ver com você nada com suas
gaiatices para mudar as coisas Doutor a
gente vem para mudar
que chega até aqui tem que mudar as
coisas eu sou doido para mudar nos
Bichos novos eu acho que é o pensamento
talvez por trás da pessoa que faz ela
ser boa na profissão sei lá qual é a
profissão eu olho que elefante é o nome
desse animal elafante mas o biólogo
quando ele encontra espécie nova ele
pode nomear a espécie eu ia colocar nome
de gente para mudar as coisas para mudar
notícia no Jornal Nacional quando
aparecer dizendo assim o Ibama acaba de
aprender um caminhão carregado de
andreias
é um verbo ela né o caminhão também foi
encontrado dois filhotes da raça Enzo
quatro casais de Maurício e dois
filhotes de Rebeca
aqui tem cara de lei dá não vontade de
criar um casalzinho de Rosângela
mas não pode porque é
tráfico animal
um elefante aqui
e vem cá E por que que você não fala com
gente gente de verdade para quê
Para quê Para falar de novo negócio de
propósito de novo para falar de novo que
eu tenho que aprender alguma coisa para
fazer um ensinamento um negócio para
cima de mim de novo aqui tu para cima de
mim para
por isso que você vem para cá então né
para o lado da criatividade O Lado Bom
da criatividade né para fazer qualquer
coisa na cabeça dá para colocar outra
voz aqui agora se você quiser é a coisa
mais fácil que tem é só imaginar só
coisa boa lado bom ser igual
comigo em Manaus isso imaginar é muito
bom o único lado bom que tem é isso
Entendi então tudo intensifica né
mas você tem cara de quem gosta né Para
falar a verdade de terça Esse sistema
imaginativo é bom ou não é
é
e você consegue sentir assim todo o
ambiente o cheiro O sons Tudo Frio a
brisa tudo até fica mais fresco mesmo eu
de roupão
por conta
das Árvores aqui atrás
Digamos que você abra os olhos não aí
passa né que também não sou crise é só
da minha cabeça é de mim mesmo abriu
Passou
e a [ __ ] ajuda sua questão
imaginativa tá vendo a vai levar para os
assuntos
isso aí nós resolvemos 2015 já fizemos
piada disso aí piada Red rola de
punhetas essas coisas larga isso aí já
fizemos outro show melhor entendi
Netflix eu tô show mais cabeça o próximo
tem que ser mais cabeça ainda mano esses
assuntos Você pensa que eu sei rapaz
ajuda da Ajuda fala para mim macho tem
dia que eu tô tão triste que eu não
lembro nem que eu tenho rola tem dia que
parece assim aqueles balão de festa de
aniversário do outro dia sabe de manhã
11 horas da manhã na beira da piscina um
balão vai ser tocar bota o pé em cima
ele fica por lá no explode presta para
nada rapaz eu tenho um laudo aqui para
você você tá precisando é de plateia
exato aí você falou uma verdade eu
preciso é de plateia mas como é que tem
platéia morre duas vezes até todo dia
como é que pode ter plateia só dá
indignação eu sei que também essa parte
imaginativa aí tem
uma consequência né Tem às vezes eu
sinto o cheiro do fundo do poço e assim
o tempo todo ainda não tem quem vive
desse jeito Tem dia que minha cabeça
fica só rolando um Eco assim sabe não
tem quando você pega um Refrão de uma
música que passa o dia todinho que você
não consegue mais teve um dia desses que
eu fiquei com aquela música na minha
cabeça na piscina
toda hora toda hora pô uns três dias
assim eu tava me esquecendo
Eu duvido tu depois desse vídeo tu ficar
com isso da cabeça na Pop 100 Ela empina
o bumbum papapapapapapapapa na piscina o
bumbum e só entra meu filho tu é doido
preenche o espaço na cabeça que é bom
que você não pensa em merda é cara mas
não é bom você ficar guardando essas
coisas para você não se faz mal
veado rapaz ô doutor Perdão eu não sabia
que era senhor não foi mal assim que
você me vê na sua cabeça assim como
desta forma Sei lá eu acho que
psiquiatra tem essa cara de quem
toda história no mundo já ouviu é tudo
se eu contar para o senhor que eu
converso com quatro elefante 5 girafa
antes de dormir você vai perguntar qual
é o nome dos elefante Qual é o nome da
girafa você não vai me entendeu
assim como doutor
Branco
meu automático
foi mas não foi com intenção não foi
sei lá é até estranho pensar configura
alguma coisa
[Música]
Me ajuda aí me dá um help que eu acho
é que eu vou achar meu amigo
alguma coisa
se eu sou a sua cabeça
você precisa se informar me informar os
seus que assim você vai poder ajudar a
fazer um mundo melhor você precisa
colorir seus pensamentos e aí
É complicado tem que ser na matriz tem
que
minha cabeça tu era loiro
fui no cabeleireiro tá mais harmonizado
fui no esteticista
sempre tem um cachorro no meus
pensamentos
[Música]
você vai parar aqui de novo
seria sincero comigo Doutor fala a
verdade eu morri eu morri
tô na sala né
[Música]
ignorância
dormir que eu ganho mais
[Música]
limpeza
talvez dê para descongelar meu coração
nessa tristeza
e tudo vai passar vai passar vai acalmar
E aí galerinha que assiste meu canal
tudo bom com vocês não esquece de clicar
em gostei e se inscrever no canal se
você não é inscrito ainda Esse vídeo foi
gravado todo de celular e a gente fez
uma making off mostrando como dá para
você fazer um vídeo legal se você fizer
um roteiro legal e bacana em casa o link
para você ver como é que foi feito tá na
descrição do vídeo não vai mudar o
formato dos vídeos Esse vídeo foi só
para voltar logo mais tem paródia é o
próximo tá depois começa a voltar os
vlog de novo e tudo mais é só um
pontapézinho pra gente se sentir bem e
seguir em frente e vamos embora Comenta
aí embaixo o que é que você acha que vai
vir de novo por aí muitas novidades hein
tamo junto é nós valeu